Before we jump into some real code,
there's one requirement that
you need to know about.
Service workers require HTTPS.
If your site isn't served
over a secure connection,
the browser simply won't
load the service worker.
The only exception is during
development where local host and
its equivalent are allowed.
While this may sound like
an arbitrary requirement,
service workers allow you to
intercept network requests,
modify them, redirect them,
even totally fabricate responses.
While I'm sure you'll
use this powers for
good, there are some
evil people out there.
By requiring HTTPS you can feel
confident that the service worker that
gets installed hasn't been tampered with
during its journey across the network.